we don't experience love as a bunch of
chemicals in our brain if you do yeah
like it's you in trouble we experience
love in the realm of language and
consciousness and relationship and and
and and if you try to reduce that to the
chemicals in your brain you're not doing
justice to the experience of that your
your and and you know I I think that
that if it brings us back to the
discussion about sam harris a we had
that we had before where there's a
there's a podcast where he talked with
it I forget who it was yet a podcast
about this notion of how reality stacks
like how you know emergent they call
emergent phenomena right how how things
come together in two identities right at
higher levels because it's not just a
quantum field like we don't just
experience it but in the end it is just
a quantum field right it is just in
terms of material substrate it's just a
quantum field and so but then how do
these different levels of reality stack
on each other and Sam kept wanting to
huse kept saying I want to explain it
with the lowest common possible thing
but that doesn't make sense because you
know like millions and billions like
there's millions of atoms in your hand
and there's no point in explaining it
with those millions of atoms instead of
explaining it with the deer like I'm
thirsty I'm going to drink a glass of
water
explaining it through the realm of
consciousness and I think that that's
yeah that's that's that's the thing is
that just because you find the material
causes of something does it mean that
you've eliminated the higher realities I
think I think it's to me it's so obvious
but I guess a lot of people aren't able
to see it but it's me it's so obvious
like I can both say that the music that
I like comes from my my iPod you know
but also comes from I don't know like
Kanye West or whatever like it and and I
can also say the Kanye West is
manifesting you know certain immutable
patterns of relationships that make it
so that I can like that music and so
it's like I don't have to eliminate I
don't have to say well I know I
discovered the secret of music it's
coming from my earphones I've got I've
got it
you dumb people who think the news
chuckles exactly it's like so you dumb
people who think that music has meaning
it's like it's all moving particles yeah
I could just imagine a music review page
that was just like every single every
single album was it's just moving
particles different way to the other
ones exactly and it's and certain
chemicals in your brain have been we
were able to see which section in your
brain is is is active yeah the problem
is that that's what you find I mean
that's what you find in at least a lot
of the people that I've encountered that
are so against religion you know they
say things like God doesn't exist and
and I think well you know what if you
think that exists means that you can
hold it in your hand you can touch it
and feel it then yes God doesn't exist
fine I'm totally fine with that
like if you think that if you even if
you think that it means that you can
contain it even conceptually then yeah
God doesn't exist right yeah because God
the whole idea of God in the in the
Christian tradition and in all the
monotheistic traditions is that God is
uncontainable that God is beyond all
concept all name all representation and
that not that the representations are
arbitrary that they help you to kind of
get closer to to the to the mystery but
that but that that God is not a thing
right and so it's really hard to argue
with an atheist who want you to prove
that God exists like he wants you like
he wants you to prove that you know that
that that tree has fallen in the forest
like you can't it's not the same kind of
proof even existentialism starts from
that perspective of realizing the
language we are using cannot encapsulate
the thing we're trying to explain yeah
is everything by definition language is
going to be a subset of it any
representation of everything is going to
be a subset of everything yeah therefore
it cannot it cannot be articulated yeah
but I think that the proper way to see
it at least at least like in it from the
Orthodox perspective we have this idea
we have these two visions of theology
when it's called apophatic theology and
catyph attic theology an apathetic
theology means this denial right this
saying that
that that God is beyond all name all
definition right that you cannot
encompass the divine in in language and
images and whatever but then the other
aspect is that because of that
everything actually does manifest the
divine right so one of the problems
people have one of the problems we've
seen in post-modernism especially is
that they'll have this apathetic moon
well they'll say something like you
can't represent reality reality is
beyond our capacity to represent it and
then they make this weird move where
they say therefore it's all arbitrary
right
all their structures are arbitrary our
social structures are constructed
they're all arbitrary but that's not the
read move the read move is then to see
that actually all of reality then flows
out of that mystery and actually points
in a very fragmented way but points
towards that unsaid mystery and so
that's what lays out the hierarchy right
that's what lays out the hierarchy of
being is is both those moves where you
say it's something beyond but then
everything is manifesting that Beyond
and it's kind of its kind of flowing out
of it
and that that that's what helps that it
helps avoid it helps avoid the absurd
aspect of existentialism in my in my
opinion at least
you